so The Last of Us episode 5 is now out
and in this video we're going to be
recapping the plot breaking down the
Easter eggs and also talking about the
game's similarities and differences
survived
endure and survive excuse me as always
this review won't contain spoilers until
the end of the video and that'll be for
people who've completed both parts now
we hop right off the back of last week
which saw the introduction of salmon
Henry with your eyes last time that
they'd follow Joe and Ellie and this is
how they randomly ended up on the same
floor as they did in the skyscraper this
is confirmed in the episode and Theory
time right and the entry centers around
flashing out their backstory along with
Kathleen's on the podcast for the show
the creators stated that she's like
Madame dufage from A Tale of Two Cities
and she says very Meek character who
ends up becoming a vengeful ring leader
said on getting revenge for the death of
her family last week we missed that
Tommy's voice actor Jeffrey Pierce was
playing the part of Perry that samskin
actually didn't have any bullets in the
chamber eagle-eyed viewers but there
were two bullets in there but that he
need to pull the trigger four times in
order to shoot Joel now in the game the
pair's origin wasn't as fleshed out as
it is here in that their Cuisine
Hartford had been abandoned by the
military in fearing that it could cause
danger for Sam Henry let him out of
there with some other survivors they
traveled in a Pittsburgh searching for
supplies and this is when they were
split from the group by a bunch of
Raiders they'd all agreed to Rendezvous
at a radio tower which is when we
learned in the game that Sam was big and
the events played out much like what we
get at the end of the episode there's
several nuts to your journey with Sam
and Henry laced throughout the entry and
we sort of get a compressed version of
it with us having the office building
ish in the sewers the sniper section
that you play through and the infected
that then swarmed the area Sam and Henry
were gray characters in the original
game but the episode very much elevates
them showing that they're willing to do
dark things in order to survive they're
of course a reflection of Joel linelli
with them both sharing the same kinds of
Dynamics now here we get the inner
workings of how they were part of
Kathleen's team and we learned that
Henry sold out her older brother the
fedra this created an uprising in the
group over through Federer which meant
that Henry and Sam had to go into hiding
in order to escape them now we start off
the episode with the people celebrating
the disintegration of Federer a flare is
shut up into the sky like a firework and
the people then shout freedom
again we have the We the People truck
and in case you missed our last video we
pointed out on that that it has roots in
the Constitution it's the first three
words that appear in it and it's very
much the people believing that they've
created their own independence you also
theorize that this could be another Taxi
Driver due to the saying we are the
people appearing in that and Ellie's
opening scene that happens in the mirror
either way with all the uprisings come
Bloodshed and the celebration suggest
deposed by the dead Federal soldiers
that now line the street those that are
still living are brutally murdered and
the sigil for them is presented with a
fire beneath hitting at the crumbling of
this era I've always been a bit hit and
miss on the hate for Federer as they did
manage to stabilize America by creating
safe zones for the people episode 1
showed that though they kill the
infected without question they try to do
it in a nice way but as with all
authorities there are those that within
that can be corrupted and evil this was
showcased in episode 3 in which we know
that they murdered some evacuees in case
they became infected in the game's
counterpart Pittsburgh you learn that
the rebels did what they did here and
piecing up things together to learn why
this was there's graffiti on federal
buildings complaining about how people
are being starved and when food ran low
obviously they kept the rations for
themselves now the trucks are on the
streets looking for collaborators and
over the townai we can hear they'll
offer Fair trials
this is clearly a [__] lie though as
we see Kathleen ordering several
collaborators to be executed in the next
scene I feel this is riffing on real
world politics and after the second
world war several Nazi Collaborators
were hunted down throughout Henry's
called a rat and Jill refuses to work
with him initially because he doesn't
want to associate with someone who
[__] over his own people to get a Lego
with fedra in the game he had a really
tense moment where they left you up
shoots creek without a paddle and I love
how this uneasy Alliance also carries
over into the show we then see a body
being dragged behind a truck and this
has several knives in it this is
complete Overkill obviously and
potentially done for a reason to show
all those that were involved in taking
down Federer when Julius Caesar was
killed he was stabbed 23 times and this
was done to show each of the
perpetrators had a hand in it and that
they were all in it together this
episode very much feels like the same
sort of thing with the rebels clearly
showing that they're willing to get
their hands dirty in order to overthrow
fedra in a changer from the game we
learned that Sam is deaf unless he talks
to Henry in sign language and has a
little little magic body can ride on
this adds even more to just how
vulnerable he is and it clearly shows
why Henry feels like he has to protect
his brother subtitle text is also done
to mimic how it appears in the game and
the font they use is exactly the same as
it is in that now we jump to Kathleen
interrogating the collaborators and one
of them gives up Dr Edelstein who we
learned last week was killed by Kathleen
or was it the next week anyway lots of
timing why me wibbly wobbly stuff when
she says that they'll be executed if
they don't give a penry and Sam but even
when they do she still wants them wiped
out this really speaks to her character
and how she refuses to let her brother's
death go unavenged her right hand man
Perry asks why the pair is such a
priority as a city still in the state of
destabilization now we learned from
Henry that the infected were driven
underground 15 years ago but they've
clearly been awakened Once More by the
revolution happening on the surface
Kathleen doesn't care though and she's
willing to throw everything she has to
make sure the characters are caught as
we learned last week this involved
overlooking a hole in the ground teaming
with infected and this short-sightedness
eventually leads to her downfall and the
end of her people throughout the videos
you've talked about how the showrunners
have constantly brought up the theme of
Love on the podcast and this is
something that's definitely seen in
Kathleen love can be good as in the case
of Bill and Frank but it also can have
hugely negative effects Kathleen loved
her brother and losing him is caused her
to hunt down all those involved in his
demise at the expense of others now an
overthrowing Federer she's pretty much
become the thing that she saw to replace
and there's a little line that hints
towards this burn the bodies spits
faster this is of course what we saw
Jill doing for veteran episode 1 and it
showcases how they're both different
wings of the same bird it's possible
that we actually saw the collaborators
bodies and if you cast your mind back to
episode 4 then you'll remember there was
a pile of them when Jill and Ellie drove
through the town this moment pulled from
the game and in that Ellie said that
they weren't infected them giving up the
doctor is very on brand as well because
they've obviously been working with
Federer and are now betraying people in
order to to survive another day that we
see is Henry and salmon meeting with the
doctor who hides them in an attics
similar to how Anne Frank and her family
hit out during the Holocaust last week
Kathleen discovered it abandon with
empty tins of food and in this entry we
see what happened during the time that
they were laying low we see Sam drawing
his character Super Sam and last week we
got a tease to this with him wearing his
orange face paint now I think one of the
running themes throughout the last of us
is how every character's childhood has
been Stripped Away because of the way
the world is humans could easily be
United Force against the infected but
everyone fights amongst themselves and
those children don't really get to live
come the end of this episode we now have
three dead kids in the series and this
comes in the form of Sarah the child at
the qz and of course Sam Ellie initially
seems to be in enjoying this world and
though she's making the most of it she's
not really seen as a kid either
described as being cargo she's just
someone who can help create a vaccine
unless she isn't really viewed as a
person I've said this in other
breakdowns but children are our future
and have having so many of them dying
means there's no hope for the human race
Humanity has stumbled on for 20 years
but when the kids start dying it won't
be the infected that get us it'll be the
fact that there's no one to carry on the
species really poignant stuff and we see
10 days going by with the pair hiding
out Sam had it so drilled into his head
that Federal of the enemy that evenness
is reflecting the artwork with the
drawings looking like how the soldiers
do in the gaming show in another night
to the game we see Henry looking out the
window and off in the distance we can
catch a yellow Bridge though this
section took place in Pittsburgh in the
source material you and the group had to
make your way to a similar one in order
to get out of the Town eventually Joel
and Ali ended up having to jump off it
and this happened after they were chased
by the Run truck
oh
on the shore they were saved by Henry
and Sam who abandoned them when a ladder
broke during the chase with the truck at
this point you then pass through the
sewers which we'll talk more about in
just a bit when we get to The Hideout
section now Sam is worried that the
doctor isn't coming and as we know he
was captured by Kathleen he told Henry
to stay strong so that his brother
wouldn't worry but we can clearly see
that this is Weighing on him finally he
decides to accept the truth that he's
not coming back and the pair now to take
their chances in the city also worth
noting that Sam has a yellow hoodie on
at this point and this is the same thing
that he wore in the original game Henry
gives him some orange face paint which
wasn't in the source material and this
is a nice little touch to add to his
character in the game you stop by a toy
store to Hideout from the truck and Sam
wanted to take a robot toy with him
Henry said no because it would just take
up space and again it's sure that kids
couldn't be kids in this world Sam what
are you doing nothing get rid of it
my backpack is practically empty what's
the rule about taking stuff it weighs
like nothing rule what is it
we only take what we have to how you
took it in the end and after making it
to the radio tower she did give it to
Sam as a little present much like the
episode he turned the next day but she
kept this tone her backpack as a
reminder of him Henry ends up checking
the street and this is when we see the
action scene from last week which Jill
crashed his truck and had to shoot it
out with the rebels I did go back and
watch this scene again to see if we
could spot Henry but unfortunately we we
can't now we do get the moment where
Joel finishes the shooting lowers his
gun and looks in that direction but it's
clear that he doesn't actually see him
seeing him as a way to safety Henry ends
up following the pair and this
eventually brings everything full circle
from last week and a nice bit of
attention to detail you can also see
that Henry has a giant flashlight on his
backpack and this is in line with the
one that he also had in the game and now
we then go to the alleyway in which Ali
climbed through the van and the pair
don't have to do this because she
unlocked the door he also goes straight
at the staircase and step on the glass
that Jill used to alert him however as
we discovered in episode 4 he's going
deaf in one ear and this is why he lay
on one side every time he went to sleep
also at noting that in episode 1 he
didn't hear Tess entering tying back
this whole deafness thing going on with
him now the gameplay sings differently
and after he chase by the Run truck You
Have To Shimmy along a walkway and this
is when you jump through a window and a
grab by Henry he thinks you're a radar
but upon seeing Ali he realizes that
you're not with them in camps where
Federer were overthrown they tend to
either kill her outcasts the kids
because they just slow the others down
where you from all the way from Hartford
really
I heard some bad stuff going on down
there yeah the military fan of his own
that's why we left
Place probably looks like this by now
this is a major reason why Henry ended
up leaving Hartford as he knew Sam would
probably be murdered by the group that
took over the military's Place Jill
almost beat Henry to death which is when
Sam stepped in with a gun drawn similar
to what we get here Henry likely
realizes that they're in a similar
situation just an adult trying to escort
a kid through a hazardous City now they
end up sharing food and this obviously
means a lot in this new world survivors
have to be even more careful because
food was how the cordyceps spread a
nurse given the limited amount of food
that they have they have to be more
tight with it now we get a scene that
sort of riffs on one from the game in
which they sit about surveying the area
in the original Henry ended up taking
Joel and Ellie to their Hideout which
was located in an office block across
the city in the game they of course want
to make levels and sections for you to
fight through whereas in the show and
not really needed so you can just skip
it and put the scenes in the same
location now you went into one of these
rooms and it had a similar sort of
layout to what we see in the show the
game had Henry's hideout location I did
just above the guy that was in front of
the entrance to the bridge and under the
cover of Nightfall you ended up
launching your plan to pass it here they
do things differently and they look over
the city and point out the exits Henry
says he's never killed anyone and though
this is technically true we do learn
that he caused someone else's death
although it's all serious with Henry and
Joel salmonelli at least have some fun
we catch here reading the pun bug to him
and get some similar moments in the
showing game
hurt you
it's been a while since that boy even
cracked a smile
[Music]
never heard that in a long time in the
game Henry and Sam were actually making
their way to the fireflies and Joel said
oh it seems like there's a lot of people
putting their stock on the fireflies
these days yeah maybe there's a reason
for that
so you don't know where they are you're
just going to drag him across the
country to find him this was ironic as
well because he he was of course making
his way across the country Without
Really knowing where they were either
anyway Henry draws up a map of the city
and tells them that they're going to be
heading through the maintenance tunnels
Henry wants Jill to help him navigate
these as they could still have infected
them Henry actually calls a click or a
clicker and you know what it's nice to
see a live-action thing not embarrassed
by the terminology that they use in the
games he says that someone he knew from
Federer said they'd been cleared out but
there is still a possibility that some
might be down there and he and Sam won't
be strong enough to deal with them all
he knows is though and the theater is
that Kathleen won't follow them because
of the danger there could be now they
head into another building and this
resembles the one that you first move
into when you storm the gate however
yeah they head underground which is when
they discover what was really going on
we get this line
I'm not my dad
which is a nod too it's just you and
your daughter
we're not related we're more like um I
promise someone I'd look after yeah
I can appreciate that now as we
mentioned earlier this is basically
combining the sewer section of the game
so that it's part of Kansas as we stated
giolinelli jumped off the bridge and
this is when they were pulled ashore by
Henry and Sam you found about washed up
along with some notes and a home in the
sewer that was once teeming with people
children were of course killed by the
bandits unless they fled here with their
parents to try and carve out a life I
was gonna say that that something like
this might have happened here but Joel
says that lots of people went
underground on outbreak day it's
possible that people ended up lying low
here and then when the infected were
pushed in the ground they wiped them out
because they'd bottle themselves in
yikes now the entrance to this is drawn
to look like a castle and this is some
yet also pops up in the game when you
first enter the sewers anyway when they
enter the room there are several things
here that are ripped right out of the
source material now against the back
wall we can see a girl drawn onto it and
there was an optional cut scene in which
Ellie played football against Sam yes
I'm saying football again I'm not saying
soccer I've had enough for you guys I've
had no you can probably hear I'm very
ill at the moment so the thumbs up is
much appreciated and then I hope it
doesn't ruin the video for you like it's
ruined my life making these videos for
you I hate you
now this plays out in a scene similar to
what we get here
uh calm down
hey Sam yes okay
ready
did you see that
let's keep it down buddy okay
to me this always made Ellie ever closer
to Sarah because Sarah also played
soccer when she was a child hey said
soccer for you guys out there you
suckers see you chump now we do get a
little subtle gesture by Joel here and
he looks down at his watch after looking
at Ellie this is Sammy that Sarah of
course gave him and looking at the watch
reminds him of the daughter he lost he
also did this in episode 2 and as we
know it doesn't work so it's not like
he's using it to read what the time is
it just shows how much Ellie reminds him
of Sarah and moments like this say so
much with so little there's a slide
which I think was in the game and also a
big sign that says house rules when you
made your way through the underground
you could spot this and the rules on
both are identical they say make sure
doors are locked ask for password if you
don't know the visitor no shouting in
noisy play run to hiding spot when you
hear the alarm now in the game you
accidentally set off one of the alarms
which alerted the infected they had
bottles inside a box on the end of a
rope and setting this off showed them
where you were we also see blue barrels
with tubes popping at the top of them
and we learn in the game that these were
used to collect rain so that they had a
supply of water now in what's my
favorite Easter egg from the show so far
we see a child's drawing with Danny and
ish on the wall this is identical to how
it appears in the game and you come
across it when traversing the sewers now
why is this my favorite Easter egg I
mean the pic the picture yeah it looks
completely and but ish yeah he actually
has an extensive backstory that you
discover through notes that you find
throughout the sewers it is a great
support in the game and he's based on
the character issue with Williams from
the 1949 book earthbite in that there
was also a pandemic and the character
ended up establishing a community of
survivors like what we see here he was
meant to look like Ishmael from Moby
Dick and this idea of being a sailor
carried across to the game after the
outbreak he went to sea for several
months but eventually he had to go to
Shore and he landed near Pittsburgh this
is the bar that you encounter after the
bridge and it's here that you discover
the first part of his story we learned
that he ended up going into the Suez and
it's here that he constructed a safe
house desperate for foolish ended up
going into the suburbs behind them which
is where he came across a family of
other survivors though they initially
just traded supplies ish ended up
inviting them down into the sewers which
is where they built the community
unfortunately someone didn't follow the
rules and they left the door unlocked
which is when the infected broke in by
the time he got there it was completely
abandoned it was a horrifying event for
those stuck inside one of the notes said
that the teachers barricaded themselves
in a nursery with some of the other
children and and had to well do what
happened at the end of the Mist you know
that ended I guess you could say life's
an ish and then you die hey
now ish actually made it and he and some
of the other survivors fled into the
suburbs which is the next area the
characters go into in both the shown
game I was wondering if this old guy was
actually him but let's hope not now on
top of this we also see that Sam has a
Savage Starlight comic these were
collectibles in the game and they told
the story of Dr Daniel estar who could
travel faster than light the cover here
is pulled directly from the PlayStation
counterpod and this is the aggression
issue brought across from it in the
second game the comics expanded Beyond
just being comics and you also collected
trading cards of characters from the
story this included Dr ukman Who was
based on Neil drockman aka the gay man
series Creator Ali also says his
catchphrase to the edge of the youth
reverse
and back
to the edge of the universe and back
endure and survive excuse me
indoor
and you know I really enjoy these
moments with them just getting to be
kids as it's summing up we haven't
really seen that much in the show now
when they take the comic out the back we
can also catch the buck two old potatoes
and me this centers around a girl whose
parents are going through a divorce and
she builds a relationship with her
father whilst the pair grow new potatoes
from some old ones initially the girl
finds the potatoes in the cupboard and
she thinks they're gross but over the
book she learns their new opportunities
from then they can grow something new
and this is similar to her parents
divorce enabling her to have a different
but new type of life this is very much
reflected in Joel and Ali who are making
something new in this world that's
falling apart around them now we don't
have any sponsors this week but we have
just launched a new t-shirt over at our
shop Zero edition The Last of Us
Inspired Real fungi top massively helps
out the channel and it helps us to pay
for stuff or overheads and everything so
we can just bring you deep Dives like
this I really appreciate all your
support anyway and just you dropping
comments really means a lot to me as it
helps boost these videos but if you want
to give something more then the link to
the site is in the description below and
definitely head over there to get some
cool merch that massively helps us out
thank you now it's at this point they
decide to wait a couple of hours and
then they decide to make their move this
causes a bit of time difference from The
Source material as you arrive in the
suburbs and played at the sniper section
during the middle of the day yeah though
it happens at night and this is because
you don't really travel through the
sewers now Jill and Henry took it out
and he apologizes for saying he's a rat
however Henry reveals what really
happened with Kathleen's brother the way
he describes him he sounds like the
second coming of Mr Beast and I bet he's
the kind of person who would always like
comment and subscribe even if the host's
voice didn't sound as good as it
normally does anyway Henry says that Sam
got sick with Leukemia and thus he had
to work with Federer to get a special
drug that was in short supply little did
Henry know this pushed the resistance
over the edge and we ended up getting
what we see in Kansas City Henry gave up
someone amazing that could have led the
people into a new world for the life of
someone he loved and we'll talk later on
about how this thematically repeats
through the show in that super special
section
now Henry guesses that y'all was a
father and similar him he'd of course do
anything to protect the ones he loves
cut a Kathleen and we see her in the
room that she grew up in with her
brother this is a donut with ornaments
and also kids playing
football again tying back this photo of
Sarah check check the Analytics
our biggest audience is America there
were planes that were playing soccer now
Perry returns with some bad news Joe and
Henry are still at large with there
being no sign of them in the city
Kathleen reveals that her brother's name
was Michael and it's possible that he
was a firefly due to a dog tag that we
find with that name on in the game might
be a reach here but Michael likely gave
people hope that there was a different
way of life and this is of course
summing that the fireflies also do the
idea of him giving people optimism is
represented in Kathleen who tells a
story about how they used to change
their rooms using their imagination
he was so beautiful
there was constant gunfire screaming and
bombing in the town but in this room
they managed to make it feel like a safe
place Michael likely did that to
everyone growing up and it really makes
you question whether Sam's life was
worth his obviously you don't want to be
killing kids but the Carnage it's caused
by handing him over shows that even
things done with the best intentions
have their own costs Kathleen said she
visited her brother in jail and he told
her to forgive last week when talking to
the doctor she said that the room they
were in could be the one Michael was
tortured at and again because of this
she can't forgive now we jump back with
Joel and Co to catch them making their
way into a bank car park this could be
riffing on a secret location in the
second game in which he traveled to West
Lake bank and got a shotgun early now
like the game once you hit the Main
Street you peppered by a sniper they
have the layout exactly the same with
them being at a high vantage point in a
house at the end of the road similar to
what happens here Jill uses cars for
cover and he makes his way down to it
before you take out the Gunner
Henry running up in the game the pair
make a break for it here but they're
almost shot when trying to escape the
game also had Raiders and houses along
the street or as this guy is just by
himself he's much older than his game
counterpart and it explains why Joel's
able to get the drop on him so easily
yours to see Joe looking out to a river
with a bridge on it which is riffing on
the one from the Pittsburgh chapter that
you had to get to I was also wondering
whether Joel was thinking should I make
a break for it
um I don't think he is but yeah let me
know below if you had that
interpretation now in the game I I
always wondered why this guy didn't move
when he saw you coming up the street his
position is clearly given away but here
we see that he's been working with
Kathleen and thus he didn't really want
to vacate this spot
he was deliberately trying to hold them
in place so goodbye Kathleen in her
group time to arrive and they then show
up at this point this whole scene riffs
on the game quite a lot and in it Jill
takes a sniper and he watches the Run
truck arrives in the show we see the
battering ram on the front being used to
clear out cars and this is something
Joel touched upon last week when talking
about how the roads were cleared
must have been some Truck Yeah they used
to stick big ass plows on them and clear
the roads for their tanks and such in
the game do you all used the gun to
shoot a rebel popping at the top that
was throwing molotovs this caused him to
drop it in the car which set it a light
and this then crashed into one of the
houses from there the infected sprung
out and this is how Sam got bit you
ended up playing to the tower as in fact
it ran to the house and that's pretty
much how the sequence ended here they
changed things up with a truck driver
still crashing but to make things even
more tense we get Kathleen holding
everyone except y'all at gunpoint she
says them kids and justifies murdering
them by saying kid style all the time
she sees Sam as being someone who should
have been left to his fate instead of
costing her her brother however fate
still has a hand to play and the truck
collapses in unleashing a terrifying
horde of infected we see one set on fire
and this is a similar effect to what
would happen when he hit one with a
molotov in the game I love this bit
because Joel couldn't get hit you're
kind of just sniping away and having a
bit of a laugh now at this point we see
a big bad blow that who is first teased
at all the way back in episode two so
there aren't super infected that explode
fungus spores on you [__] I hope not you
could also hear the creature growling
into the cracks in the floor last week
and this makes a really big entrance in
the game he actually faced off against
the first one in the school scene during
build section but I'm kind of glad we
got the greatest love story ever told
instead and they kept his arrival for
this scene in the game it was a one-hit
kill if they grabbed you and blood as
would actually stick their fingers in
your mouth and rip your head apart Perry
gets killed in the exact same way and
seeing this happen in the background I
was like that dab they went there
although Ellie is hiding out we can see
a child clicker crawl to the SUV to get
it child clickers don't appear in the
game and I'm guessing that this was used
because it later kills Kathleen and she
was very much saying how kids didn't
really matter Henry and Sam are pinned
down like what happens in the original
work but Ellie saves them and they make
a run for it she stabs them using her
knife and this is also a tactic that she
bust out in the source material as we
said Kathleen gets killed and in an
e-refinal shot we see the infected
running towards the City they likely
destroy the resistance as they lie
asleep in their beds and I doubt that
even Dorothy would want to get back to
Kansas eh now in the game Henry said
Pittsburgh at skeleton Crews at night
which is why they opted to move out then
and I can imagine it being a similar
thing set up in Kansas this means it's
going to be a very short-lived
Revolution and because Kathleen couldn't
forgive it's led to this downfall now
the group make it to a motel and we see
Henry is really shaken up by it but the
kids have got to it okay anyway the
conversation in the game is a lot more
light-hearted with them talking about
Tommy before moving on to the group not
showing up it's Tommy's birthday that's
all he wanted to do is just
find two Harleys and drive cross country
I could die happy if I could just ride
one around the block
what was it like
it's good it's real good
can you believe this guy come on man
give me details describe it you know
what you two deserve a little privacy no
no Ellie Ellie this isn't just any
regular motorcycle okay you get on that
bad boy you feel that engine nothing
like it oh yeah how would you know
seen it in my dreams
okay
[Applause]
I don't think anyone from my group is
going to show up in the show Joel
invites Henry and Sam to join them on
the quest to find Tommy and this will
give them a new Fresh Start the game
also changes things slightly and with
Sam he was clearly wrestling with what
would happen now that he'd been bit
is everything all right
yeah everything's fine
well
have a good night
how's it that you're never scared
who says that I'm not
what are you scared of
scorpions are pretty creepy
um being by myself
scared of ending up alone
what about you
those things out there
one of the people are still inside
what if they're trapped in there without
any control of their body
scared of that happening to me
okay
first of all we're Team now okay we're
gonna help each other out and second
they might still look like people but
that person is not in there anymore now
in the show alien Sam said about reading
comics and he eventually asks if she's
ever scared we get a scene that riffs on
the game with the answers being written
down and shared between the two whereas
in that it was a conversation like the
previous cutscene Ali says she's scared
of being alone and this plays into a
character moment that we'll talk about
in the spoiler section Sam also asks if
it's still you inside when you turn and
he then shows her his bite this is
unlike the game is in that he keeps it
to himself however he does pull up his
trouser lag to reveal it like what we
get here Ellie shows just how naive she
is because she believes her blood can
cure him and it very much plays in her
believing that she is the vaccine she
sort of has a massage complex and
believes she can heal the sick but this
of course doesn't end up working out
it's very much a kind of I don't know
kids view of Science and he gives Ali
another cruel dose of reality in the
harsh light of day in the game Henry
gelinelli sleep in the same room and
when she went to get him up she
discovered he'd been turned we see Sam's
back first like what we get here but
Ellie spent the entire night with him
while still likely took over while the
scenes play out in a similar way and
I'll drop them side by side so you can
see the differences as well as what they
kept oh
damn
that smells good
morning
where's Sam
I let him sleep in for once
oh
well if you wanted to join us you can go
wake his ass up
Sam hey
what the hell
[__] he's turning
oh
that's my [__] brother
screw it
foreign
oh my God
save
oh no
soon
Henry
I'll stay here Henry
what did he do
he's easy easy
I'm gonna get that gun from me okay
oh okay okay easy this is your foot
nobody's fault him
it's all your fault Henry
now they both end in Salmon Henry's
death and that closes out another entry
with some big characters passing away I
think every episode except Force had one
big death in it and the first had Sarah
Tess was in the second Bill and Frank in
three and now Henry and Sam here it
actually hurts more than it did in the
game because we know that Henry gave up
Michael in order to save his brother he
still had to kill him though once he
became infected and it shows how dark
and Bleak this world actually is even if
you save someone this can still be taken
away from you and this all can happen at
a moment's notice outside they bury the
yellow car smacked it at me outside they
bury their bodies and now he creates a
makeshift gravestone using Sam's Board
in the game he actually came across a
child's grave and it's just as
depressing as it is here
that's too small great I forgot to leave
that stupid robot on his grave what
should I do with it I mean what I want
to talk about it no why not how many
times do we need to go over this
things happen and we move on
that's enough
you're right
I'm sorry let's get to Tommy's Ellie of
course forgot to put the robot toy on it
but here she remembers to drop Sam's
Board she writes I'm sorry and clearly
deals with the survivor's Guild of the
situation Ellie is still alive from her
bite whereas Sam isn't and her actions
the night before potentially also cost
Henry's life to pass it out and in the
moment that Rifts on their Silhouettes
and the credits we close out with them
journeying out west now for the next
part of the video we're going to be
talking about game spoilers and things
that will probably ruin the story for
you if you haven't played them what the
[__] is wrong with you why the [__]
haven't you played The Last of Us where
five episodes Stephen you started
anyway the two characters that I think
reflect Joel here are Kathleen and Henry
who both end up doing bad things out of
love Kathleen's love ends up turning her
into a bitter and vengeful person and in
the end this Dooms her entire town this
could be similar to how Joel was
affected by Sarah and his attack at the
end Dooms Humanity because we don't get
a vaccine I know people kind of go back
and forth over whether the vaccine would
have worked or not but the second game
doesn't kind of spell out that there was
a pretty big chance now how is Henry
like Joel well Henry's actions to save
Sam ended up leading to Michael's death
he put the life of the person he loved
bubble else and this could be reflected
in Joel's actions to kill the fireflies
at the end that's more of a well they're
both pretty tenuous but I thought I'd
just bring it up here in case they end
up going that route in the series I'm
pretty sure they will at this point
because so far it's been almost
identical to the game above the bill and
Frank episode and the odd change here
and there it's also possible that
Kathleen is somewhat of a mirror of Abby
as both a revenging someone that was
murdered at which eventually leads them
losing a lot now Ali saying she's scared
of adding up alone could possibly play
into the next episode which will
potentially take them to Jackson I
haven't seen the trailers yet as we make
these videos before they release but I'm
guessing that the next entry centers
around them relying with Tommy in the
game jail pretty much wanted to fleece
Ellie off to him and she ended up
running away for a bit Joel and Tommy
headed out to get her which is when they
came across red airs but eventually they
managed to catch back up to her Glam
promised to take care of the fireflies
himself and I can't imagine that
basically being the plot of the next
entry now as for my thoughts on this one
I did think it was a solid way to build
up last week and even though I knew it
was coming the Henry and Sam deaths were
still devastating just leave that
feeling of hopelessness that the last of
us is built upon and you can see how the
characters become completely jaded and
self-centered no one's really gonna look
after them so they have to look after
themselves unless they push themselves
in this one track mind based solely on
Surviving this is what Joel had but
Alias made him realize that there's more
life then just making it through the
day-to-day bill of course discover this
and it's very much layered throughout
the entire season I think Henry and Sam
was spotted as well as you couldn't
really ask for more accurate adaptations
of them yeah I know Sam wasn't deaf but
he played the part of a kid trying to be
a kid in the apocalypse really well and
it did provide a devastating ending that
I think a lot of people are going to be
shocked by I actually found myself
almost being like Joel at this point and
as the guys just put Tessa's death at
the back of his mind and kept going and
that's what I do once they ended up dead
these characters they have big passings
and I'm I'm like well just gotta keep
surviving I guess can't stand around and
feel for them it really shows how well
crafted that the series is but I do have
some faults with it I kind of felt like
Melanie lynskey was a bit weak and
personally I don't know why anyone would
really follow her I get the whole
brother dying put her in charge but she
didn't really come across someone that
could command others just a nitpick for
the episode and yeah if you disagree
that's fine yeah let me know below now I
hope you enjoyed the breakdown either
way and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below we are running a competition right
now and giving away wakanda forever to
three subscribers on the 15th of
February and all you have to do to me
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch so make sure you check out
one of our breakdowns on screen right
now which will definitely be going over
some more stuff that you're gonna love
if not thanks for saying through the
video apologies for my voice again and
yeah thanks for being with me you take
care yourself peace